حسنًا ، هذه هي السفينة الرحمة
التي يطالب العرب بها
السلطات البريطانية وسلطات جبل طارق
بالإفراج الفوري عنهم يقولون إنها
احتُجزت كعمل قرصنة وهدد
عضو سابق في الحرس
الثوري الإيراني بضرورة قيام سفينة بريطانية
في مضيق هرمز.
يتم إلقاء القبض عليك إذا أردت نوعًا ما للاحتجاز
أثناء قيامهم بالسلطات البريطانية وسلطات جبل طارق
والاحتفاظ بالشرف هنا
ولكن في الخلاف هنا ، تقول إيران إنهم
لا يصدقون سلطات جبل طارق ، هل ذكرت
السلطات أن
لديها سببًا للاعتقاد بأن هذه السفينة
كانت  توجهوا إلى مصفاة نفط سورية
تنتهك عقوبات الاتحاد الأوروبي
ولهذا احتجزوها الآن
يقول الإيرانيون إنهم يعتقدون أن
الولايات المتحدة طلبت من بريطانيا
إيقاف هذه السفينة لأنهم يقولون إنها
حصلت على نفطهم على متنها وأنه لم
يكن '  لن أذهب إلى المصفاة أبدًا ،
لذا فهذه مواجهة دبلوماسية كبيرة في الوقت الحالي هي
التهديد بضرورة
الإفراج عن هذه المصفاة وإلا ستفشل سفينة بريطانية  إن
الأسير هو في الأساس ما يقوله
الإيرانيون بينما تقول السلطات البريطانية
وسلطات جبل طارق
إنهم يواصلون التحقيق في هذه السفينة إلى
أين كانت تتجه وماذا كانت تفعل
، ويبدو أنها ستبقى هنا
لبعض الوقت.
المواجهة الدبلوماسية NIC
Robertson CNN قبالة ساحل جبل طارق